[Music]
this is harris what would i do without
you this is harris just the soul of
discretion one would never know she'd
been but for the polish on my knobs
that's what we are by the invisible
women kiss me once and kiss me twice
then kiss me once again isn't it divine
500 pounds 500 quid for a drink when i
put it on nothing else matters my eddie
would love to see me in a dior gown what
has been over a long time your head is
never coming back
there's a moment dreaming
that's where you are
you're a dreamer
you should have been receiving a war
widow's pension comes quite a tidy sum
who is my attic it's a sign from my
angel what are you going to do i'm going
to buy a dress a christian dior from
paris
please let me squash you out no no no
hang on a minute i saved every penny
scrubbing floor so i can buy this rock
excuse me but it would be my honor to
have you view the collection as my
a jaw dress guests designed to astonish
how will you do that this is harris you
are nobody invisible
mother may i give you a lift
what was i thinking come in here i'm
just a cleaner from london no your
cleaner dreams are the most beautiful
gown in the world
it's not sewing it's making moonlight
you dare to follow your dreams mrs
harris
this is not possible not at all where
are you going mrs harris to see the boss
this is house these are for you from sri
lanka
i've spent too long on my own wishing my
life away you don't want to do the same
thing this is your chance
i have never encountered anyone like you
come on girls follow me today there's a
new woman a modern woman
i thought it was too late
now i'm not so sure
who's that bloke looks the master
himself mr dior he looks like my milkman
[Music]
you